[Musik]
ich schwöre dass ich meine kraft dem
wohle des deutschen volkes widmen seinen
nutzen mehren schaden von ihm wenden das
grundgesetz und die gesetze des bundes
wahren und verteidigen meine pflichten
gewissenhaft erfüllen und gerechtigkeit
gegen jedermann üben werde es ist kurz
nach zwölf als olaf scholz im bundestag
seinen alt ablegt zwei stunden zuvor
nimmt er die wahl zum kanzler an es gibt
applaus glückwünsche und
erinnerungsfotos und oben von der
tribüne sieht seine vorgängerin zu an
seinem ersten und ihrem letzten tag im
amt
und damit ihnen allen einen schönen
guten abend an diesem 8 dezember der
reich war reich an besonderen bildern
und momenten dir die wir ihnen zeigen
wollen ebenso die reaktion und
einordnung es gibt auch fußball
champions league und dazu spielt damit
ihr chris sehr gerne einen schönen
verdammt
historischer staat historischer abschied
angela merkel tritt nach 16 jahren
endgültig als kanzlerin ab und er olaf
scholz ist jetzt der neue regierungschef
frisch vereidigte genauso wie sein neues
bundeskabinett mit dem er schon die
erste sitzung abhielt über den
machtwechsel die vielen premieren und
den tag patricia wiedemeier
selten verlief eine regierungsbildung
und eine amtsübergabe so geräuschlos so
harmonisch wie diese am nachmittag im
kanzleramt angela merkel übergibt die
amtsgeschäfte an ihren bisherigen
vizekanzler olaf scholz
sehr geehrter herr bundeskanzler lieber
olaf scholz ich weiß aus eigenem erleben
dass es ein bewegender moment ist in
dieses amt gewählt zu werden sie an
vielleicht dass es eine spannende
erfüllende aufgabe ist auch eine
fordernde aufgabe das war eine große
zeit in der sie kanzlerin dieses landes
waren und sie haben auch großartiges
bewegt dass wir so lange so viele
gemeinsame erfahrung sammeln konnten das
wird mir dabei helfen schönen dank mal
nochmal für ihre arbeit er werde die
nordostdeutsche mentalität die hier
herrsche beibehalten versprach scholz am
ende ändern werde sich erst mal nicht so
viel der stil im kanzleramt wird sich
vielleicht nicht ändern aber im
bundestag heute morgen da war dann doch
einiges anders als sonst fotos 11 es
waren ausnahmsweise erlaubt angela
merkel saß auf der tribüne da sie kein
mitglied des bundestages mehr ist
zusammen mit seltenen besuchern mit ex
bundestagspräsident thierse und
ex-bundespräsident gab die ära merkel
sie geht nach 16 jahren kanzlerschaft
heute zu ende verabschiedet wurde sie
mit stehenden ovationen
mit spannung erwartet dann das ergebnis
der geheimen wahl mit ja haben gestimmt
395 abgeordnete
damit hatte olaf scholz die
erforderliche kanzlermehrheit erreicht
auch wenn nicht alle abgeordneten der
ampel koalition für ihn gestimmt haben
mindestens 15 aus den eigenen reihen
fehlten olaf scholz ist damit der vierte
spd kanzler in der geschichte der
bundesrepublik weiter ging es im schloss
bellevue dort erhielt scholz vom
bundespräsidenten seine
ernennungsurkunde
etwas später dann auch die künftigen
ministerinnen und minister steinmeier
nutzte die chance der ampel ein paar
ratschläge zu geben ermahnte sie müsse
geschlossen gegen die pandemie vorgehen
und einer spaltung der gesellschaft
vorbei die mehrheit hat ihn ein mandat
für mutige schritte des wandels gegeben
aber wer mutig voran geht wird sorge
dafür tragen dass die weniger starken
schritt halten können auch die
ministerinnen und minister wurden
anschließend im bundestag vereidigt
bevor sie dann ihre jeweiligen ämter
übernahmen glückwünsche gab es reichlich
aber auch unterstützung sie werden es
brauchen bei all dem was sie sich
vorgenommen haben
und olaf scholz er stellte sich am
nachmittag den fragen der zdf sendung
was nun bevor dann das neue kabinett vor
einer stunde zusammenkamen viel zeit zum
feiern bleibt der neuen regierung nicht
zu drängend sind die probleme
allen voran die bekämpfung der korona
panda
und wir gehen jetzt rüber nach berlin zu
theo koll theo historisch wehmütig
emotional erwartungsvoll wie muss man
diesen tag einschätzen von allem etwas
historisch ja auch wenn der begriff
vielleicht etwas inflationär gebraucht
wird es ist immerhin die erste ampel
koalition im bund mitten in einer
pandemie mit großen reform aufgaben vor
der politischen brust emotional ja auch
dass dieser parlamentarische beginn hat
ja immer etwas von ersten schultag aller
art nervöser neu beginnen das war
diesmal vielleicht besonders spürbar
weil der bundestag deutlich verjüngt es
143 abgeordnete sind zwischen 30 und 39
jahre alt und 50 sind sogar unter 30 bei
denen war das besondere des tages noch
etwas stärker spürbar in die
aufbruchstimmung mischt sich aber auch
sehr deutlich die kommende lasst das
neue kabinett hat gerade zum ersten mal
getagt morgen ist schon die nächste
ministerpräsidenten runde mit
entscheidungen zur pandemie also eine
kanzlerschaft mit kaltstart dankeschön
theo wir wollen gleich nochmal weiter
sprechen ja olaf scholz hat eine
intensive zeitreise und verwandlung
erfahren vom lockigen juso rebell zum
neuen bundeskanzler
die spd schickte ihnen zwar sehr früh
ins kanzler rennen aber ernsthaft
geglaubt an ihn hatten die wenigsten
noch bis zum sommer blieb das ja sodann
strauchelte die konkurrenz scholz legt
den umfragen immer stärker zu und gewann
schließlich über diese karriere die
mehrfach beendet schien lars bohnsack
als olaf scholz 2018 finanzminister wird
kann er nicht ahnen wie wichtig das amt
in krisenzeiten noch werden sollte
sowohl die korona pandemie aber auch die
hochwasserkatastrophe im sommer dieses
jahres verschlingen milliarden die
finanzielle hilfe kommt scholz ist der
mann mit dem geld in deutschland
die war super mit der wir das notwendige
jetzt tun in seinem politischen leben
hat scholz immer wieder davon profitiert
dass er eher unterschätzt wird dabei ist
der mann zweimal zum ersten
bürgermeister von hamburg gewählt worden
alle sagen sie möchten dass sich die
führung der hamburger spd übernehme dann
bekommen alle das was sie bestellt haben
seine führungsrolle bekommt allerdings
deutliche kratzer als der g20-gipfel in
hamburg in chaos und gewalt versinkt
seit 20 jahren spielt der gelernte
jurist ganz vorne mit in der politik als
spd-generalsekretär verteidigt er die
agenda politik gerhard schröders als
arbeitsminister setzt er die rente mit
67 mit durch viele entscheidungen die
die spd zerrissen haben kleben auch an
ihm auch deshalb muss scholz sich immer
wieder in den eigenen reihen verteidigen
ich bin der meinung dass sich ein echter
julie sozialdemokrat bin die niederlage
im kampf um den parteivorsitz ist
vielleicht die schmerzhafteste die er
erleidet doch scholz wäre nicht schulz
wenn er hinschmeißen würde im gegenteil
er kämpft sich zurück wird zum
kanzlerkandidaten gekürt
wir spielen auf sieg der beginn von
scholz kanzlerschaft ist überschattet
von zwei finanzskandalen sowohl bei der
wirecard pleite als auch bei den comics
geschäften eine hamburger bank haben die
oppositionsparteien weiterhin fragen an
den ehemaligen finanzminister das system
scholz das ist expertise beharrlichkeit
tiefschläge wegstecken können genau
damit hat es olaf scholz geschafft ins
kanzleramt zu kommen
nochmal zu theo koll nach berlin theo es
gibt da jetzt keine 100 tage schonzeit
für diese bundesregierung große vorhaben
noch größere herausforderungen aktuell
was wird denn scholz anders machen als
merkel also interessanterweise dürfte ja
einiges so ähnlich machen wir angela
merkel hat diesen leisen führungsstil
auch er wartet ja oftmals lange ab um
dann zu einer entscheidung zu kommen die
auch gerne mal gängigen erwartungen
widerspricht man konnte das
beispielsweise gerade bei der ernennung
der spd kabinettsmitglieder erleben die
herausforderung sind gigantisch er hat
aus der pandemie ein enormes
finanzdefizit zu bewältigen und braun
doch eigentlich noch zusätzliches geld
für die anstehenden reformprojekt
stichworte digitalisierung und
klimawandel und letzteres erfordert ein
noch nicht wirklich vorstellbar großen
wirtschaftlichen und gesellschaftlichen
umstellungsprozess den scholz versteuern
muss und dass zwischen weit
auseinanderliegenden vorstellungen
seiner ampel partner der
wirtschaftsorientierten fdp und klima
dirigistischen grün also dass ihm
zugeschriebene enorme selbstbewusstsein
wird er brauchen vielen dank theo koll
nach berlin jedenfalls gibt es viel zu
tun und das neue kabinett scholz hat
schon losgelegt nach der ernennung durch
den bundespräsidenten und dem amtseid im
bundestag an die neuen gesichter und die
namen da werden wir uns alle in den
nächsten wochen und monaten noch
gewöhnen müssen und thomas concia der
hilft uns schon mal
das neue kabinett 17 köpfe neben dem
kanzler acht frauen acht männer
vizekanzler ist robert habeck als
wirtschafts und klimaschutzminister geht
er das grüne hauptziel an ökonomie und
ökologie zu verbinden
als liberaler finanzminister wacht
christian lindner über den haushalt sein
credo möglichst keine neuen schulden
neue akzente setzen will annalena
baerbock als aussenministerin mit einem
härteren kurs gegenüber russland und
china heute auch ihre ernennung als
erste frau im außenamt auch das
innenministerium wird erstmals weiblich
geleitet nancy faeser von der session
spd möchte den rechtsextremismus stärker
bekämpfen
den kampf gegen korona soll karl
lauterbach als gesundheitsminister
weiter führen mit seiner expertise als
epidemiologe
der liberale marco buschmann übernimmt
das justiz ressort von christine
lambrecht spd sie ist
verteidigungsministerin und heute mit
militärischen ehren im amt empfangen
worden
ihre parteikollegin svenja schulze wird
entwicklungsministerin volker wissing
fdp ist für verkehr zuständig und für
ein weiteres ampel anliegen den ausbau
der digitalisierung um bildung und
forschung kümmert sich bettina stark
watzinger und um familienpolitik einen
spiegel grüne mit steffi lemke bekommt
die umweltpartei auch eine
umweltministerin und mit cem özdemir den
landwirtschaftsminister er ist der erste
bundesminister mit türkischen wurzeln
arbeitsminister bleibt hubertus heil
neue ist ein bauministerium mit klara
geywitz aus brandenburg wolfgang schmidt
schließlich soll im kanzleramt olaf
scholz dabei helfen das regieren zu
koordinieren nicht einfach mit 17 köpfen
aus drei parteien
und zum regierungswechsel da gibt es ein
zdf spezial gleich im anschluss nach uns
darin auch ein was nun mit fragen an den
neuen kanzler scholz und in diesen
historischen tag in berlin haben wir
natürlich auch online geschaut haben das
sortiert und der zdf heute und in
unserer heute app finden sie weitere
interviews und infos zum neuen kabinett
und den plänen
die omikron virusvariante breitet sich
nach angaben der
weltgesundheitsorganisation
rasant über den globus aus in 57 ländern
wurde sie schon nachgewiesen der
virologe drosten rechnet damit dass
deutschland ab januar ein problem mit
omikron haben wird und auch piontek und
pfizer haben heute daten zur
virusvariante vorgelegt und die zeigen
dass selbst zweifach griff geimpfte oft
nicht genügend antikörper haben um
omikron unschädlich zu machen julia
schröter hat die neuesten informationen
knapp zwei wochen lang hat bei montech
geprüft wie gut sein impfstoff gegen
omikron wirkt erste ergebnisse zeigen
nun zwei impfdosen bieten keinen
ausreichenden schutz vor einer infektion
mit omikron vor einer schweren
erkrankung schützen sie aber wohl
weiterhin die dritte impfung bietet dann
wieder einen deutlich größeren schutz
forscher aus südafrika und frankfurt am
main hatten zuvor ebenfalls impfstoff
daten veröffentlicht die in eine
ähnliche richtung weisen
zum einen muss man ganz klar sagen dass
die antikörper die durch die impfung
induziert werden immer noch gegen
omikron schützen können aber ich brauche
deutlich mehr das heißt er ich brauche
ungefähr 25 fach mehr es gibt andere
ergebnisse sagen sogar 40 fach mehr
antikörper um omikron zu neutralisieren
das bedeutet nur zweifach geimpfte haben
mit omikron ein erhöhtes risiko sich
anzustecken das liegt daran dass omikron
vor allem amys bike protein notiert ist
dort locken die antikörper normalerweise
an und machen das virus unschädlich
wegen der mutationen klappt das aber
nicht mehr so gut
daher läuft es wohl auf einen
angepassten impfstoff hinaus
gemeinsam mit unserem partner weiter
arbeiten wir weiter an einem an die
omikron variante angepassten impfstoff
das haben wir vor kurzem begonnen für
den fall dass es nötig wird unser ziel
wir wollen einen hohen und einen
anhaltenden schutz erreichen
im märz könnte so ein neuer impfstoff
zur verfügung stehen allerdings sollte
bis dahin niemand warten der einzige
schutz aktuell ist sagen experten sich
jetzt impfen und postern zu lassen
und noch immer sind die korona zahlen
hoch heute vor allem bei denen die in
verbindung mit cupid 19 gestorben sind
527 innerhalb eines tages meldet das
robert-koch-institut der höchste wert
seit februar
hinzu kommen 96 1601 neuinfektionen
binnen 24 stunden
2415 mehr als vor einer woche die sieben
tage incidents ist dagegen leicht
gesunken auf jetzt 4 127
verletzt man sich auf dem arbeitsweg so
ist das versichert wie ist es aber im
home office das bundessozialgericht
sorgt jetzt für klarheit unfallschutz
besteht auch auf dem weg vom bett ins
arbeitszimmer so das gericht geklagt
hatte ein arbeitnehmer der auf dem weg
vom schlafzimmer zum schreibtisch
morgens stürzte und sich verletzte die
berufsgenossenschaft erkannte das nicht
an und wollte nicht zahlen
große razzia heute in gleich zwölf
bundesländern im visier schleuser die
illegale arbeitskräfte an große deutsche
logistikunternehmen vermittelt haben
sollen etwa 2.000 beamte von
bundespolizei und zoll waren im einsatz
wie hier in berlin
zehn mitglieder der bande konnten
festgenommen werden sie sollen bis zu
1000 menschen vor allem aus der ukraine
und moldawien mit gefälschten papieren
ausgestattet haben
vor gut 100 tagen haben die letzten us
soldaten afghanistan verlassen
dann übernahmen die taliban die
herrschaft mit desaströsen folgen das
land ist politisch isoliert die
wirtschaft liegt am boden unicef schlägt
alarm 18 millionen menschen sind auf
humanitäre hilfe und gerade für kinder
verschlechtert sich gerade die lage mit
jedem tag aus afghanistan berichtet
jetzt katrin eigendorf
seitdem die taliban an der macht sind
hat sich für die mädchen alles verändert
nur noch bis zur sechsten klasse dürfen
sie die schule besuchen die elfjährige
user und ihre freundin wollten immer
ärztinnen werden
ich will patienten behandeln
und für das land arbeiten
träume die die taliban zerstört haben
ein paar straßen weiter sitzt die 8
jährige fatima am straßenrand sie friert
ist hungrig doch als schuhputzer in muss
sie für ihre familie geld verdienen
etwas anderes hat sie nie gelernt
die welthungerhilfe gibt in kabul mehl
und öl aus nothilfe für die immer mehr
menschen anstehen
es gibt viele familien die haben oft
über fünf tagen nichts zu essen und
müssen
95 prozent der familien haben nichts zu
essen
in folge müssen immer mehr kinder wegen
unterernährung behandelt werden
seit wochen fordern hilfsorganisationen
mehr unterstützung für afghanistan
das schicksal von millionen menschen
liegt auch in den händen der
internationalen gemeinschaft
und mehr von katrin eigendorf zur lage
in afghanistan im auslandsjournal um 22
uhr 15 und ich muss noch eine korrektur
nachhängen bei den infektionszahlen
neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden
69.000 600 und 1 die internationale
raumstation bekommt nach mehr als zehn
jahren mal wieder besuch von touristen
ein japanischer milliardär und sein
assistent sollen zwölf tage in der iss
bleiben
morgen starten starteten sie zusammen
mit einem russischen kosmonauten vom
weltraumbahnhof baikonur ihre zeit da
oben haben sie sich viel vorgenommen auf
der liste steht unter anderem eine
partie badminton
ja dann sind wir jetzt genau richtig
sport und bei dir christin und du legst
los mit der fußball-champions genau
abschluss gruppenphase rb leipzig kann
für die europa league planen wohl mit
dem neuen trainer domenico tedesco
dessen verpflichtung soll unmittelbar
bevorstehen berichten übereinstimmend
verschiedene medien auftrieb gibt auch
das 2 1 gegen manchester city
übergangs coach achim beierlorzer kann
sich immerhin freuen rb macht gegen
manchester city die schwachen bundesliga
auftritte vergessen 1 0 durch dominik so
rösler in der 24 spielminute per port
jonas team eher harmlos und so bereitet
andres silva in der zweiten halbzeit
seinem kurzzeit trainer erneut freude
die gäste dann noch mit anschlusstreffer
durch riad war es aber auch mit foul und
roter karte für kyle walker leipzig sieg
trotzdem der schlusspunkt in der
champions league weiter geht es für die
sachsen in der europa league nächstes
jahr
viel spannung verspricht die gruppe g
alle vier vereine haben noch die chance
auf die achtelfinal teilnahme auch der
tabellenletzte der vfl wolfsburg für das
team von florian co feld zählt gegen den
osc lille allerdings nur 1 der sieg
was kann man erwarten vom vfl wolfsburg
nach zuletzt enttäuschenden vorstellung
gegen mainz 0 zu 3 verloren wir müssen
vor einigen punkten intensität dynamik
tempo
uns schon deutlich verbessern sondern
letzten spielen helfen könnte die
rückkehr des kapitäns kuhn kastells
wieder im tor nach auskurierter cupid 19
erkrankung jetzt geht es mir wieder gut
ich habe einige gute trainingseinheiten
hinter mir und fühle mich auch wieder
wieder sehr gut gelänge der gruppensieg
wäre das historisch noch nie ist ein
team in dieser phase der champions
league am letzten spieltag von 4 auf 1
gesprungen
das wäre es für borussia dortmund geht
es in europa league weiter zum abschied
aus der königsklasse gelang ein 5 0
gegen besiktas istanbul
alle tore und highlights des sechsten
champions league spieltages von 23 uhr
an den sport studio live sowie auch zdf
heute.de und in der zdf- heute- app
einfach reinklicken dann finde
ann-christin das aber auch nur fast in
sachen sport weil sportlich zeigte sich
heute auch der neue ernährungs und
landwirtschafts minister erste mir nach
der urkundenübergabe im schloss bellevue
und nahm er stadtauto das ebike urkunde
auf den gepäckträger geschnallt und los
ging's zur ernennung und auch das hier
haben wir gefunden ein korb gratulations
äpfel für kanzler scholz vom
abgeordneten seidler na was gesund ist
zum start ins neue amt blumen gab es
wohl schon genug die ära merkel ist
jetzt jedenfalls offiziell zu ende
dann haben wir wie jeden mittwoch noch
die lottozahlen und die gewinnzahlen
lauten 15 16 18
26 39 und 44 die superzahl 5 weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf.de und auf der zdf textseite 557 ja
eher trübes dezember wetter morgen mit
schnee beziehungsweise regen ob es auch
sonne gibt erfahren sie gleich von katja
horneffer über den machtwechsel
berichten auch die heute journal
kollegen ab 21.45 außerdem der neue
gesundheitsminister lauterbach im
interview mit marie slomka das war es
von uns schön dankeschön abend und bis
morgen um 7
[Musik]
guten abend an der wolken spirale von
tief harry hat sich hier über den
westalpen ein neues tief entwickelt und
das brachte uns heute regen schneeregen
und schnee und gefährlichen gefrierenden
regen da sehen sie hier sehr schön wie
dieser schnee und schneeregen weiter
nach osten gezogen ist am alpenrand
werden insgesamt innerhalb von 24
stunden bis zu 20 oder 40 zentimeter
neuschnee fallen können bis morgen früh
und in diesem schmalen band richtung
thüringer wald sind es immer noch 5 bis
15 cm es bleibt auch in dieser nacht
glatt nicht nur dort wo es weiter
schneit oder wo schnee regen fällt denn
die temperaturen sinken auf plus 2 bis
minus 4 grad im nordosten bleibt es
morgen kalt dauerfrost - ein minus zwei
grad im westen gibt es auch rein
zumindest fünf oder sechs grad und auch
morgen schneit es weiter es flott leicht
hier in der osthälfte freund hier
sieht's aus zwischen der nordseeküste
und im sauerland und von westen kommen
neue schnee und regen wolken haben am
freitag fällt dann in der südwesthälfte
schnee oder regen am samstag dann nur
noch in süddeutschland und am dritten
advent wird es von nordwesten deutlich
milder guten abend